Mà Nhìn không trong ai mít ưu tướng chính phủ phạm mi chính thạm dự hội nghiệp cách nhà lãnh Thạm Brex Mử dòng.
Chúng tôi có hội nghiệp thức định Brex tại Khá Gián theo lần mời của tổng thống Ngá Bladimia Poojin.
Sở tham gia của Việt Nam được đánh xa kháu và năm anh Nhìn không trong ai mâm Việt Nam chính thức chử thành đối thác Brex.
Đông thờ là nấu tiên tham dự hội nghiệp thức định Brex Mử dòng tại Brasil.
Đánh giáo buc tiên quan trọng trong chính xích đối ngoại đáp phương chủ đồng hội nhau của tế.
Đây là dịt đề Việt Nam thu hệ hợp tám với các đình kinh tệ mừng nổi,
đã biệt trong các lĩnh vật có thể mạnh bộ trở như đổi mối sáng cao qua công nghệ năng lượng tái cao hay tại chính.
Brex đang tựng bức mở giọc anh gồn thông qua việc kết nặp thêm cơ đối tám.
Mở giọng không ra hợp tám chín ba chủ của chính.
Từ hồ nghị cá ra năm ngoái để viêu năm nay, nhóm thứ tục đẩy mạnh tại các quản trị quan cầu,
đứng tới phát triển bao trường và cố bằng hơn.
Chú đen năm nay, giọng brazil đứa chú tịch luôn phía nền đề sớt,
nhìn mạnh hợp tác phương nằm, thuộc đầy quan trị quan cầu, bình vững và bình đăng.
Việt Nam đã biệt quan tâm các lĩnh vật thấy mạnh của Brex như công nghệ năng nghiệp thông mạnh,
năng lượng xa c化 kài trịng số.
Về các nếu hoàn nên sẽ tham xa của Việt Nam đã thể hiện sự công nhận đối với vai cho của Việt Nam,
trong hệ sinh khai hợp tác nằm nằm, đang lổi lên những một lực lượng tái đện hình cục sẹt thế giới.
Bởi vì thủ tướng phạm mi chính tham sữa hội nghiệp thực tình Brex mần dòng,
năm nay nghiệp công trong em lâm, Việt Nam cảm kết đồng hành cùng cái nước đăng phát triển,
trong việc kiến tạo chực tự của tế đã cửc và bình vững hơn.
Lá bất tiến quan trọng định vị vui phai cho của Việt Nam,
tại các tiến trế đã phương quan trọng của tế kiện hành mốt.